[Music]
all right we're discussing with james in
st
augustine florida he's got a house
payment 50
of his take-home pay they just started
their financial peace journey and his
friend offered to let him
sell his house and move into their
trailer for 800 a month a friend was an
fpu grad
as well um that's a fair summary of what
you told me so far
pretty much yeah what's your household
income
household income is about 41
000 my wife just started working um
she well she she's been working and took
some time off uh
she just started back and so uh when she
works a full year i want to say it's a 7
200 that she brings in she just works a
couple nights a week as a
at-home care nurse
7 200 a year yeah it's
uh she works like a couple nights a week
it winds up being like 150 a week that
she that she takes home
okay and she's a nurse uh yes sir
yeah she um she started doing that a
while back just to
get make a little extra money you know
to help out okay so how much is your
house payment
the house payment with uh well the
actual payment is like 925 but with the
mortgage and the property taxes it bumps
it up like 1500
3.53 cents
so you're dropping it about five or six
hundred bucks now is your wife staying
at home because there's kids
uh yeah we have three kids a
four-year-old a three-year-old and uh
one turns a year old in a couple weeks
oh y'all are in the trenches james
the little ones what's up y'all are in
the trenches with the little ones
so oh yeah and so the the
four-year-old's very opinionated and
he's not
totally on board with the house selling
so that's part of my question
the four-year-old the four-year-old has
something to say about this yeah
let me help you with this so he doesn't
get a vote okay um
he doesn't have a vote so i'm trying to
say how do i
go about being a benevolent dictator
yeah we're just gonna it's gonna be an
adventure we're moving pack your stuff
um the uh i have i could sell it for
if i could get 300 for it which it's
worth that i would list it for like 320
and try to get 300.
but if i did that i could pay off the 29
000 in debt
plus i could uh after paying off like oh
in the house i have about 175 on the
house
pay that off plus the 129 uh i mean not
the 29 rather that i have in in debt
besides the house plus i could get six
months
all in the emergency fund all in one
shot and still be sitting on 110 for a
down payment on another place
why don't you just do that why do you
have to move to the trailer
well because i have to be somewhere in
between because i have to sell the house
and have the money studying on it
because in this area no you don't i
don't
no you put the house up for sale and you
accept a contract on it and you go buy
another one
contingent contingent upon the closing
of your house
okay it's done every day you just need
to move down in houses off yeah
yeah yeah you could find something james
in in the area you want to be in or
somewhere close to it
that is better than this uh trailer
option that you would feel great about
that you could still afford still pay
after all the things you're saying
it's just going to happen without moving
to the trailer how long you've been
working this plan a month
uh uh maybe a week okay
let's let let's push pause here okay
you don't need to sell your house right
now i'm i'm not sure that this is all
that's going on
so you you're just you're just thrashing
around in a brand new
set of enthusiasms that you have uh so i
you may need to sell the house but let's
wait six months
let's work the plan for six months the
other thing i'm seeing here is is if
your wife is a nurse
she can do a lot more hours and still do
child care
for herself i still take care of her
children
she can pick up three twelves and really
make a good living
and uh do that on some weekends and
stuff for a short period of time and you
guys clean up some of these messes
i suspect if you clean up these messes
and your income changes because she's
working more than a couple of
150 a month worth as a nurse that means
she's not working at all
then i i think we rearrange when we look
at her career track
and again if she has a desire to be a
full-time mom i'm not saying that's a
bad thing
the beautiful thing about being a nurse
is there's a lot of different ways you
can structure
uh making some good money more than that
around kids
yes and with kids and all that kind of
thing so
that's exactly what i would do in this
case i would just wait a little bit
and let's see how this works out you
know like after the first of the year
if you're still struggling and you
haven't made any progress
which i would be surprised you may want
to sell the house and move down but i
think right now that's going to be
premature
so hey thanks we appreciate it